all right let's take a call right here
hey theo man it's nathan from nashville
now it makes me really excited to hear
that you might move down here
and i just want to offer perspective
thank you for calling nathan
i appreciate that brother sound like
you're reading does it sound like he's
written this and is reading it did you
pick up on that riley
sounds like it yeah thank you
about a year or so ago i was kind of
obsessed with moving to l.a
in my van with the idea of laying it all
on the line for my dream
and maybe by doing this god would you
know buy the ticket to the dream at the
price of
the ultimate sacrifice you know but um a
lot of my mentors here said they're like
dude just slow down you're kind of where
you need to be
and i just want to let you know man like
dash feels changing and growing
and if you move down here you'd kind of
be at the floor
the ground floor of a movement just well
first of all thank you man i appreciate
this call
young fella and i'll say this man
definitely
is getting a van and driving somewhere
apart is that
laying it on the line i guess in a lot
of ways it is
you know you definitely you could easily
get fleas you're probably gonna at least
have a pet at some point
i don't trust the person that has the
van but not the pet that lives in it
with them
at least that guy i feel like is a
little bit more
non-murderer you know because you can't
murder
if you if you if you have a place if you
have a van
you're not going to bring some uh a
person home and murder them with the
animal right there
that cause then there's two degrees of
what's going on
there's you being murderer and there's
the animal watching
that you know there's um there's just
so when i see a man with a van with no
animal
now a bird it doesn't count i'm talking
dog
a bird doesn't count a cat doesn't even
count a cat is just a
it's just a freaking uh four-legged bird
and but when you get that animal if you
get a van with an
animal that guy aimer you know that guy
will try to screw you probably or do sex
with your give you
you know and make you a little grilled
cheese or something and maybe have you
listen to a little bit of widespread
panic or something like that and
freaking
you know he'll want you you know he'll
do some henna tattoos on one of your ass
cheeks but he's not gonna
murder you but i feel like you get into
a van that has
no animal in it
that's murder town right there
what do you think riley you had any
experience with anything like that
i have not honestly
what else is going on man i'll say this
uh
i appreciate the call i appreciate the
call you calling and saying that good
things are here things are happening
let's hear a little bit more of whatever
you had to say brother
to give you an example my band is a
psychedelic
gospel funk group and oddly enough we've
been
kind of welcomed and embraced and um
again just things are moving and
changing it's not just
well yeah but i one way to get welcome
and abrasive if you if your band does
everything
you know we're a country uh
you know we're country zydeco
uh emo uh
drywall can we play here and it's like
yeah we you know
sure you can you know as long as you
refinish the kitchen you can play
wherever you want
like if you have two if you have so many
options to a band
you know if you if you're like oh we do
acoustic acapello
uh jamaican um
sort of it's like kind of like a six
nine dixie chicks mash-up then people
are like
uh they can't say no
so i think to challenge yourself brother
try one type of music
because if you got that christian disco
funk trap house
choppin screwed paul wall meets
uh paul simon
hell i don't even know what i'm at that
point i might as well just damn
you know drive my car into a damn amoeba
music
into an abandoned record shop but thank
you for the sentiment of this call man
and sentiment when you think of cinnamon
it's almost like cinnamon and mint
somebody put them together
let's hear the rest of this and oddly
enough we've been
kind of welcomed and embraced and um
again just things are moving and
changing it's not just country right
and asheville might not be known for
comedy but man we could sure use a king
down here
and you know music and and comedy go
together like peanut butter and jelly my
friend
well i appreciate it man i appreciate it
man music and comedy are interesting you
know a lot of comedians
will end up getting into music
riley mao do you know that i do now
a lot of comedians will get into music
you know sinbad is a famous
kind of black asian kind of comedian
and he does music now he has a band
steve martin famous
white man uh
you know he might have been italian i
don't know what he was but he also he
did music he does music now he plays a
banjo
jim brewer does music
he does music and he was you know
he definitely i mean he you know he
barely he he seems like yeah
you know he's kind of a rescue kind of
man he
um a lot of a lot of communities get
into music
i think it's because at a certain point
sometimes you get
i think it's why anybody does anything
or changes it up
you know your voice and your your humor
become an instrument and then after a
while you're like i wanna i wanna play a
different instrument
you know i wish i could play the piano
i wish i you know because your voice and
your humor it's just a it's just the end
it's just an instrument that's in you
some people's instrument in them is
is their voice you know to sing some
people is uh um
[Music]
you know uh do
you know um speed
you know def signaling
you know what is that called you know
what i'm talking about really
hand hand gestures um
what's the name of it i think it's def
signaling but
but they have speed competitions now for
def signaling
you know you'll see you know the four
people are trying to rattle off
you know half of uh you know half of um
[Music]
you know flowers for algernon or
something they're just reading it as
fast as they can with their hands
but everybody has a different you know
people have a different
play in a different instrument some
people may do bow and arrowing
and you just get it sometimes you're
tired you get tired you know
i don't want to do oh you know i don't
want to sing i want to try something
else
i want to try something else so i think
that's why a lot of comedians sometimes
will get into music eventually because
they want to play something else than
the instrument they've been playing
which is their sense of humor
it's just a refined instrument that's
all it is it's just like
singing but it's
just a little different i mean i mo at
least four times a day i think about
playing the piano
i just i'd like to play it
um so
but but yeah thank you for the nice call
good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one